>> Tucker: LAST WEEK ON THE
SHOW, WE COVERED THE SENTENCING
OF ROGER STONE, WHO IS THE MOST
UNDESERVING OF ALL THE
CASUALTIES OF THE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION HYSTERIA.
HE RECEIVED MORE THAN THREE
YEARS IN PRISON.
HE WILL BE OVER 70 WHEN HE GETS
OUT.
OFFICIALLY, HIS CRIME WAS LYING
ABOUT E-MAILS.
IN HIS FIRST DAYS, HE WAS A
TRANSPARENCY POLITICAL HIT JOB.
WASHINGTON WANTED HIM IN PRISON.
BECAUSE FOR 40 YEARS, HE WAS
TRUMP’S CLOSEST POLITICAL
ADVISER.
AMY JACKSON WAS A JUDGE
APPOINTED BY OBAMA.
SHE’S AN OPENLY PARTISAN
DEMOCRAT.
SHE’S MADE NO POINT ABOUT HIDING
THAT.
JACKSON LET THE FOREMAN STAY AND
DEFENDED HER.
JACKSON HERSELF LIED ABOUT THE
CASE.
SHE CLAIMED THAT STONE WAS
PROSECUTORED BECAUSE HE COVERED
UP FOR THE PRESIDENT WHEN THE
CHARGES HAD NOTHING TO DO THAT.
AMY BERMAN JACKSON IS A DISGRAY
TO THE JUDICIARY.
IT’S FRIGHTENING THAT SHE HAS
POWER AND SHE DOES.
WE SAID THAT LAST WEEK.
TODAY DURING A HEARING, JACKSON
ATTACKED US.
AGAIN SHE LIED AS SHE DID IT.
JACKSON ACCUSED THE SHOW OF
INVADING THE PRIVACY OF THE
FOREMAN OF THE JURY.
WHEN IN FACT, THE JUROR HERSELF
HAS SPOKEN PUBLICLY AND REVEALED
HER OWN IDENTITY.
MANY MEDIA OUTLETS PUBLISHED HER
NAME INCLUDING "NEW YORK TIMES,"
CNN AND THE WASHINGTON, ALL OF
WHICH JACKSON APPROVES OF
BECAUSE THEY’RE ON HER SIDE.
THEN SHE ACCUSED THE SHOW HOFF
HARASSING JURORS AND ENCOURAGING
VIOLENCE AGAINST THEM.
THAT’S INSANE.
WE DID NO SUCH THING.
JACKSON SAID THAT WE’RE
ANTITHETICAL TO OUR SYSTEM.
NOT ONLY IS SHE CORRUPT AND
AUTHORITARIAN, SHE HAS NO SENSE
OF SELF-AWARENESS WHATSOEVER.
JEANINE PIRRO JOINS US TONIGHT.
JUDGE, THANKS FOR COMING ON.
CAN YOU IMAGINE A FEDERAL JUDGE
IN THE MIDDLE OF A SERIOUS
PROCEEDING, LIKE DOES STONE
DESERVE A NEW TRIAL, IN THE
MIDDLE OF THIS LASHING OUT WITH
POLITICAL ATTACKS AGAINST A TV
SHOW, SHE WENT AFTER THE
PRESIDENT BY NAME.
WHAT DOES THAT SAY ABOUT HER?
>> TUCKER, I SAT AS A JUDGE IN
CRIMINAL FELONY CASES AS WELL.
THIS IS FEDERAL.
I’M STUNNED AT HER BEHAVIOR.
ANY JUDGE THAT CONCERNS HERSELF
WITH THE MEDIA OR THE PRESS
NEEDS TO GET A THICK SKIN OR
WEAR A FEW ROBES.
SHE SHOULD NOT BE WORRIED ABOUT
YOU OR ANYONE ELSE.
SHE’S GOT A JOB AND SHE NEEDS TO
STAY IN HER LANE.
EVERYTHING YOU SAID ABOUT HER IS
ACCURATE AND RIGHT ON POINT.
SHE IS A JUDGE THAT SHOULD BE
OUTRAGED THAT A FOREPERSON ON A
JURY THAT CONVICTED A MAN ON
SEVEN COUNTS MAY HAVE LIED TO
HER.
MAY HAVE EXHIBITED SUCH JURY
BIAS THAT IT WOULD DEMAND A NEW
TRIAL.
BUT NO, SHE’S MAD AT YOU, MAD AT
THE PRESIDENT.
SHE WANTS TO HAVE A HEARING ON
WHETHER OR NOT THE JURY BIAS
MANY PRIVATE BECAUSE SHE DOESN’T
WANT ANYONE INTIMIDATING THE
JURY.
HERE’S THE BOTTOM LINE.
THE JUROR FOREPERSON OUTED
HERSELF.
WE KNOW SHE’S AN ANTI TRUMP
PERSON.
SHE POSTED MANY THINGS ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP, ABOUT RUSSIA,
ABOUT ROGER STONE AT LEAST ONCE
AND SHE’S A PARTISAN.
SHE RAN FOR CONGRESS, THIS IS
THE KIND OF STUFF THAT WE SEEK
TO FIND OUT IN A VIOR DIRE.
THE FACT THAT SHE WOULDN’T
RECUSE HERSELF WHEN SHE’S
PREJUDGED THE ISSUE BY SAYING
THIS JURY ACTED WITH INTEGRITY
AND INTELLIGENCE, HOW DO YOU
KNOW, JUDGE?
HAVE YOU SPOKEN TO THE JUROR?
DO YOU KNOW WHAT WAS POSTED?
DO YOU KNOW HOW SHE ANSWERED THE
QUESTION?
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT HER
BACKGROUND?
DID SHE WANT TO GET ON THAT
JURY?
EVERYTHING IN MY GUT TELLS ME
SHE WANTED TO GET ON THE JURY
AND DENIED DOING ANYTHING THAT
WAS PARTISAN.
SHAME ON THE JUDGE.
>> Tucker: SHAME ON HER.
SHE SHOULD BE IMPEACH.
SHE’S CORRUPT, OUT OF CONTROL
AND MUZZLED ROGER STONE.
HE’S NOT ALLOWED ON THE SHOW.
SHE THREATENED TO SEND HIM TO
PRISON AND BEING ATTACKED DAILY
BY CNN.
HOW CAN A HAPPEN?
>> WE HAVE NEVER HEARD OF
ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
NEVER HEARD OF A DEFENDANT WHO
HAS BEEN CONVICTED AN SENTENCED
AND TOLD HE CAN’T TALK.
HIS LAWYERS CAN’T TALK.
WE’LL PUT THEM IN JAIL.
SHE’S A PARTISAN.
SHE’S THE ONE THAT PUT PAUL
MANAFORT IN SOLITARY CONFINEMENT
WHEN EVERYBODY KNOW ME IN THE
LEGAL COMMUNITY, WHY IS HE IN
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT?
SHE’S A PARTISAN.
EVERYTHING, INCLUDING HER
REFUSAL TO RECUSE HERSELF, NOT
HAVING A HEARING ABOUT THAT.
CRITICIZING YOU WHEN SHE SHOULD
BE WORRIED ABOUT THE FACT THAT
SHE’S A JUROR FOREPERSON OUT
THERE SAYING I AM UPSET THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL DECIDED THAT
THIS SENTENCE SHOULD BE LESS.
THE SENTENCE, MISS HART, HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH YOU.
YOU DECIDE THE FACTS.
THIS JUDGE IS ON THE WRONG SIDE
OF JUSTICE IN THIS CASE.
SHE’S ALIGNED HERSELF WITH
SOMEONE THAT MAY HAVE DISRUPTED
JUSTICE IN A COURTROOM AND SHE’S
PREJUDGED IT AND TAKEN THE SIDE
OF THAT PERSON.
IT’S WRONG.
>> Tucker: TERRIFYING THAT
SOMEONE LIKE THAT IS ON A
FEDERAL BENCH.
ROGER STONE NEEDS A PARDON.